daily life is changing in Malaysia with
coronavirus cases soaring in Southeast
Asia the government is introducing
drastic measures closing its borders
almost entirely no locals can get out
and no foreigners can get in koukin
quarantines for those who've just
returned they need to do a health check
and a self quarantine for 14 days there
will be restrictions on the entry of
tourists and foreign visitors businesses
schools and universities will be shut
only essential services like
supermarkets will operate the late-night
announcement from Malaysia's leaders
sparked panic buying in neighboring
Singapore authorities say there's no
danger of food supplies running out as
the border between the two countries
would remain open for transporting goods
in Indonesia where cases are also
steadily rising the president urged
people to change their behavior with
this current situation it's time for us
to work from home to study from home and
to pray from home it's a suggestion not
an order the president says the time
isn't right for a national lockdown yet
Indonesia has tested around a thousand
people for the virus in a population of
more than 270 million the World Health
Organization has urged authorities here
to scale up their testing to get a
better understanding of just how
widespread the virus is in Hong Kong new
travel restrictions will start later
this week all foreign arrivals except
those from Taiwan will undergo
quarantine for 14 days or medical
surveillance
Gani gone those are some your sub go
home we are doing this to make sure the
achievements were made from our if it's
over the past two months don't go to
waste in who Bay where the outbreak
began authorities say the peak of the
epidemic is over some forty thousand
medical workers deployed to the province
are now leaving
now we are returning home and I'm
excited that we were victorious against
the epidemic we have all happy while
China edges closer to the end of this
crisis its doctors are offering advice
to countries yet to see the worst of the
outbreak test early and test
aggressively Jessica Washington al
Jazeera Jakarta